[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and the obi-wan series
has quite gone by so quickly that i
can't believe we're at the finale now
episode six is imminent and before it
releases i thought we'd go through our
theories on the finale before we learn
the answers
this is one big theory time every time
it's your time and obviously i'd love to
hear yours as well so make sure you drop
a comment below now episode five ended
with riva finding the hollow projector
after hasher dropped it behind when he
had to bail organa had left a message on
there discussing luke skywalker and we
closed out with us watching the boys
sleep like we were obi-wan bloody creepy
that mate sitting on a hill watching him
with binoculars but moving on i think
this teases that riva will of course be
heading out there in order to get him
she's been abandoned by not only ob1 but
also darth vader and assistant to the
regional sith lord aka the grand
inquisitor now this is something that
she experienced in her childhood when
she was left at the jedi temple to fall
victim to the clutches of darth vader
though we discovered in episode 5 that
she very much wanted obi-wan as a way to
enact her endgame on veda i think she
also feels a lot of anger towards the
jedi in general obi-wan of course return
to chorus and but he ended up leaving
instead of staying behind to help the
survivors such as her although she was
stabbed by vader as a kid we discovered
that she ended up going to the
inquisitors
you came to us from the gutter i think
she'll likely try and win favor with
them once more and that she'll see lucas
being away to get back into the good
books however she could also end up
using him as bait and she knows that
obi-wan will probably be returning there
and thus she can just wait it out until
he gets back now though that seemed like
the most pressing thing i think the
early part of the episode will focus on
obi-wan and the rest of the group
fighting vader and his forces this is
because we got this line from rokin that
explained the situation they'd found
themselves in
our hyperdrive is down
and they're behind us
now if you cast your mind back to the
sizzle reel for the series then you'll
remember there was a lot of concept art
shown in it absolutely all of these
except one have popped up in the series
so far this includes obi-wan and eop
fortress inquisitorius the inquisitors
landing on tatooine the village in
episode 3 daryu vader talking to riva
through a hologram and the t-47
airspeeders the one we haven't had yet
involves obi-wan and vader fighting
amongst the flames on board what looks
like his devastator star destroyer
though this was initially thought to be
mustafar judging by the metal grey
paneling there i think this is probably
still just a ship this needs to be a
major battle as it's kind of the one
fight the entire show is built around
and going into it this is what i think
people are the most hyped for i really
want to see vader with the helmet off
and i'm hoping that at some point in the
battle it ends up getting damaged which
leads into it having to be removed we
had something similar in the final
battle during the force unleashed and it
would be such a cool way to amp things
up hayden christensen also hasn't really
been in the series all that much and
even most of the moments in the suit
were played out by stuntmen hayden has
been used so heavily in the marketing i
think it's a real missed opportunity if
they don't bring him out and this would
be the perfect place to do it i think
this fight is going to be a major thing
in the sixth episode and that vader and
his forces will capture the rebels as
they either drop their off or just after
it they've been hunting the jedi for a
long time and capturing those that
control a path will give them a lot of
extra info so i think that's why they're
going to be hot on their pursuit now
there is the potential that leia will
end up coming face to face with vader at
some point and judging by the lines of
dialogue in a new hope she had met him
before so they could be using these
moments in the series to add some more
context to that before we get into the
latter parts of the finale now leia will
obviously need to be dropped over at
alderaan because we know she spends a
long time there so i think that will
likely happen and then bale will talk to
obi-wan about the message again which
will make him realize he has to get back
home sooner rather than later i'd love
to see the reaver and luke's scenes
placed alongside the vader and obi ones
and i think would be great to have the
tense more dialogue driven moments
getting juxtaposed by the lightsaber
battle on board the devastator a huge
shout out to the kind of funny podcast
who talked about the upcoming show
recently and they brought up the idea
that uncle owen could end up being the
one who tries to talk riva down joel
edgerton hasn't really featured in the
show all that much and it could cement
how protective he is of luke this could
mirror their first encounter on tatooine
in which he talked about protecting his
family and having to do it here would
sort of be a bit a bit meta-like poetry
and rhyme now river sorry no we were
waiting there for ben and using lucas
bait would allow for some really human
moments with owen that would show things
from his point of view for once i really
like this theory and it would bounce
nicely between the action of the veda
fight along with the ten scenes of riva
potentially killing luke and owen i know
we already know the outcome of this but
i read a hilarious theory saying that
riva could kill luke and then he
couldn't have been cloned and the one
that we follow in the main trilogy would
have been a copy this entire time i
think this would be funny as in such a
big few to the entire franchise that i
hope they do it because i'm a [ __ ]
nutter
anyway we obviously know how the vader
and ob1 fight is gonna go due to the
aforementioned storylines i do think
it's a shame that this series has had to
fit to the confines of basically making
it so they can't change anything that
could disrupt a new hope and because of
this this series has felt rather limited
in what it can do because it currently
takes luke off world and haven't go on
adventures they've shifted the focus to
leia and if the reaver stuff is true
it's unlikely that she'll even get her
lightsaber out hope you want to explain
what one was to lucan and you hope so i
think they're not even going to be able
to have her just get it out and start
waving it around the air now they could
do something where they potentially
mirror him being a kid and her being a
sith lord which would play upon her
childhood in which she came face to face
with anakin whereas he ended up stabbing
her riva could wrestle back and forth
over what to do and potentially she may
decide against using it because of the
ties it has to her early life now this
could also set up the way that i think
the final showdown between the pair will
go riva obviously feels like she was
abandoned as a child and this has been
shown at numerous points in the season
even when she discovered the underground
railroad in episode 3 she seemed angry
that she had to go become an inquisitor
whilst other jedi clearly survived and
thrived i think that obi-wan will
explain the situation to her and that in
doing so it'll show he isn't the monster
that she thought he was in protecting
luke it's very much making up for the
fact that he left the other younglings
to their fate and she'll realize he's
not the kind of person who'd say [ __ ]
them kids now another thing that also
needs to be kept in line with canon is
that all the inquisitors are dead by the
time we get to a new hope this leaves
riva with one of two options either she
goes back to vader in the fortress and
tries to win favor or she flees into the
galaxy there are rumors of ending
reshoots and a second season potentially
in the works so they could possibly go
with the latter i do think that she will
discover that luke is anakin's offspring
and that obi-wan might explain that he's
the best chance they've got in actually
taking vader down this will make her
realize that she can still have her
revenge but in order to do that she has
to let him live knowing the information
about luke would also be pretty valuable
and i think that she'll either end up
hiding it by going off into the galaxy
or that she herself will be killed this
would mean that vader never finds out
where obi-wan is and that he doesn't
discover luke is also his child it also
in some ways allows riva to get her
revenge because luke going on to stop
vader completes her mission from a
certain point of view now lastly there's
also the matter of qui-gon jinn i was
expecting obi-wan to be at his lowest
point come episode 5 and then he'd
finally get a message from him which
would inspire him to do more however i
think they're probably saving that until
the end of the season the whole series
has been about a lost obi-wan finding
his way again and qui-gon appearing at
the end would be the cherry on top for
him he would have finally learned what
happened to anakin and though this was a
failing he could realize that he'll
right the wrongs of the past in
protecting luke it would bring
everything full circle
and sort of be a bit like poetry all
right anyway that's the end of theory
time your time is it right it's wrong we
don't know we'll find out soon at their
time and of course love to hear your
thoughts so make sure you comment below
and let me know we are running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of everything everywhere
all at once on the 15th of july and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts and theories we
picked the comments at random on the
15th and the winners of the last one on
screen right now so if that's you then
message me on twitter heavyspoilers if
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our brighton of
the last episode which will be linked on
screen right now whenever all the cool
easter eggs in it talked about our
theories explained the characters and
just generally had a blast hopefully see
you over there but if not thanks for
sitting through the video take care
peace